baseball season really starts today and
I thought would kick things off in style
with a living legend out here in Los
Angeles that means welcoming Hall of
Fame pitcher for the Dodgers Sandy
Koufax let's get him out here
Danny Koufax so cool good to have you
join in yeah
that's not that's not Sandy Koufax sure
it is okay no offense sir
Sandy Koufax is white this man is white
really also Sandy Koufax is a kind of
famously Jewish and we're right in the
middle of Passover so sandy let's hear
the four questions if you don't mind
monies to nom holiday has a nicole
hallelu it's not working okay Andy I
never realized you were such a racist
what why can't a black man play Sandy
Koufax in this sketch it's the 21st
century for God's sake isn't it time we
move past worn out stereotypes and
embrace the future unburdened by the
prejudices and hatred of the past
shame on you Andy Richter shame on you
this has been casting screw-ups covered
up by racial indignation I'm Barack
Obama and I approve this message
[Applause]
you